[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique nous ouvrons aujourd'hui le
dossier de la santé
emmanuel macron vient de présenter une
réforme globale du système de santé et
avec cette réforme nous allons poser la
question enfin des médecins pour tous en
nous concentrant sur le dossier de
l'accès aux soins dans les zones rurales
mais aussi en ville une question que
nous allons poser à nos quatre invités
fadila khattabi bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député la république en marge de
côte-d'or et membre de la commission des
affaires sociales à l'assemblée qui
traite donc les sujets de santé
gérard larcher bonjour vous représentez
et défendez les usagers au sein de
l'organisation france aso sentez-vous
présidée par ailleurs le conseil
territorial de santé de côte-d'or
aurélien vaillant bonjour mangin vous
êtes médecin membre du syndicat mg
france et vous présidez le groupement
des professionnels de santé du pays
beaunois qui a servi de modèle
on va en parler dans la réforme et andré
accary bonjour bonjour président les
républicains du conseil départemental de
saône et loire vous avez innové on a
beaucoup parlé en france en lançant une
campagne de recrutement de médecins
alors comme en médecine justement on va
d'abord faire un diagnostic on parle
beaucoup de déserts médicaux
plus largement qu'elle est la réalité
gérard larcher vous de votre point de
vue défendant les usagers dans un
département comme la côte d'or par
exemple il manque des médecins il n'en
manque beaucoup
alors sur le nom de médecin je sais pas
mais il manque effectivement tout ce
qu'ils aient accès aux soins permanence
des soins notamment ses skis le plus
crucial
il ya à peu près la moitié du
département qui est en sous-effectif et
lorsque les gens appellent au secours
pour avoir un médecin
ils peuvent être dans une zone où on est
obligé d'appeler dans une autre zone
pour avoir quelqu'un il n'y a pas de
réponses aux 15 dans leur secteur et
avec des gens par exemple qui n'ont pas
de médecin référent alors qu'en théorie
tout le monde devrait là tout le monde
devra en avoir mais effectivement il ya
des manques et puis en gros les deux
grands problèmes et sur la aujourd'hui
c'est le ski et permanence des soins et
urgences et puis
le problème des ehpad ou qui retourne
d'ailleurs sur la médecine la permanence
des soins avec eux souvent les ehpad
envoie les gens aux urgences même quand
enfin souvent quand ils soient pas
comment faire on donnerait un carré
avant de lancer ce plan de recrutement
de médecins vous aviez je suppose vous
aussi fait le diagnostic dans un
département comme la saône et loire
alors c'était parce qu'il en manquait
parce que vous saviez qu'il allait
beaucoup en manquait à l'avenir que vous
avez décidé de vous lancer là dedans on
en parlera très bien évidemment en fait
c'est en 2015 où j'ai fait le bilan de
ce qui pouvait prétendre large de la
retraite d'ici trois ou quatre ans et je
savais que 50% de mes médecins
généralistes pouvait prétendre en 2015
la retraite d'ici 2019
donc il fallait vraiment prendre entre
guillemets le taureau par les cornes
parce que déjà là il en manquait avec le
diagnostic aussi que ce qui avait été
tentée marchait pas jusque bien sûr
parce que le département comme beaucoup
de collectivités avaient pris des
dispositifs soient du co financement
soit en effet des outils pour essayer de
permettre d'attirer des médecins
généralistes dans nos territoires
urbains ou ruraux et puisque la première
problématique est générale et le bilan
était vraiment très très modeste voire
presque inexistant et c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu complètement inversé et avoir
finalement la solution la plus complète
ce haut de lanark hautement c'est c'est
un programme très complet pour vraiment
essayé de remettre des médecins va y
venir vous à nous expliquer ça aux liens
payants
chez mg france vous évalué le manque à
combien en fait est ce qu'on peut le
dire comme ça sinon il n'y a pas de nom
parce que c'est plutôt générationnel
comme levier président et c'est plutôt
leur façon de travailler qui a changé
est à la fois sur le temps de travail à
la fois sur la façon de travailler et
c'est plutôt sale après midi s'il faut
qu'on s'adapte à ce qu'on a envie de
faire nous menons nos collègues jeunes
médecins généralistes pour qu'on
arrivait à juguler justement ce fut
patients qui en plus a changé la
population a changé aussi c'est ça aussi
la grande changements qu'on doit la
charge de l avis plus longtemps et donc
du coup plus de personnages et a envie
de faire des soins de plus en plus à
domicile voire des fins de vie à
domicile
donc tout ça sûtra supplémentaire pour
nous sur le terrain sa diva khattabi
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été tentées
est annoncé sur ce sujet là dans le plan
santé il ya un certain nombre de mesures
on va dire il n'y a pas eu de décision
quelque chose de coercitif qui serait en
voyons tous les jeunes médecins ou une
partie qui sortent de leurs études dans
les campagnes pour combler le problème
de votre point de vue c'est pas une
solution
nous non non non ce que je voudrais dire
donc par rapport à ce plan santé il est
issu c'est le fruit quand même de
consultation depuis des mois et des mois
qu'il y à aussi à la clé un but c'est un
budget donc de 3 milliards cats qui est
prévu pour pallier les manques notamment
en professionnels de santé et donc il
est ambitieux mais les choses ne peut
pas être résolu en un an alors qu'il ya
des décisions qui n'ont pas été prises
depuis 30 ans au moins
donc par contre je souscris pleinement à
ce qui vient d'être dit concernant le
manque de professionnels
mais ce que j'ai envie de dire comme ça
a été ça d'obliger les médecins à la fin
de leurs études à tous aller et que ça
les années s'installer ouais bah je
faisais minable 14
c'est un peu provocateur mais je pense
que du coup si elle n'est pas non plus
une réponse absolue on avait essayé de
le faire rappelez-vous avec puisqu'il ya
un manque d'infirmières on avait mis un
dispositif réciprosanté à la région et
sous la présidence de françois patriat
pour répondre aux besoins effectivement
notamment en milieu rural
moi je pense que il faut travailler en
étroite collaboration avec les
professionnels de santé
réorganisés aussi bien sur l'offre au
niveau des territoires
et puis effectivement y mettre les
moyens et ses skis après ce qui est
prévu dans ce que vous avez réagi tout
de suite rapport sur l'idée que les
forces et les médecins il faut pas voir
qu'il ya une solution miracle l'année
prochaine santé sont organisés depuis
des années justement pour trouver des
solutions pour créer innover pour
attirer les jeunes le fait que
maintenant les jeunes viennent avant de
choisir leurs spécialités médicales dans
nos cabinets voit toute la qualité des
soins qu'on peut faire la diversité des
soins qu'on fait et maintenant on voit
qui est un changement sur le terrain que
les jeunes qui choisit beaucoup plus un
minéral et maintenant il faut qu'on
arrive à les faire s'installer en
libéral et ça c'est la grand jeu do not
voulons donner des raisons quoi aider
et leur montrer que c'est toute la
qualité de travail qu'ils auront et les
possibilités qui vont souffrir qui
n'auront peut-être à l'hôpital c'est pas
une lutte hôpital ville
mais quand on connaît qu'un modèle qui
est l'hôpital on va pas aller quelque
chose qu'on connaît pas et c'est là la
grande en jeu actuellement et autres
fans tous mes collègues on y travaille
depuis le dire aussi précisé
effectivement que les professionnels de
santé sont extrêmement bien formés
compétents dévoués mais qu'ils
travaillent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles et aujourd'hui
moi je peux comprendre quand on est un
jeune médecin
et bien qu'on ait envie d'avoir aussi
une qualité de vie c'est à dire de
pouvoir partir en vacances de passer du
temps avec sa famille d'aller chercher
les enfants pourquoi pas à l'école
notamment son secteur maintenant que
c'est beaucoup féminisée
donc tout cela bien sûr est nouveau pour
nous amener à l'expérience de la
saône-et-loire andré accary vous vous
avez fait le choix effectivement de
salariés des médecins alors on disait
les aides ça marchait pas en revanche là
on est même surpris ça fonctionne
j'ai beaucoup de médecins acceptent
d'être salarié bien sûr d'abord c'est
pas que les jeunes en plus puisque
finalement les médecins que qui sont
recrutés en saône et loire vont la
moyenne enfin l'âge va de 28 à 61 ans
donc finalement on répond à une attente
quel que soit l'âge des professionnels
en tout cas des médecins
certains ont choisi d'arrêter leur
activité libérale pour venir dans le
dispositif de saône et loire
d'autres au contraire c'est en sortie
d'études qu'ils ont choisi de devenir en
ce noir parce que finalement le ce
modèle là il ne le trouvait pas ailleurs
alors c'est quoi le modèle c ils font
moins d'heures ils sont pas tout seuls
iliad immobilier il ya de
l'administratif qui a fait pour eux il
ya tout ça d'abord un médecin n'exerce
pas pour des questions d'argent donc
dans le modèle que j'ai construit ce que
ce serait pas une généralité
dans le modèle qu'ils étaient construits
c'est un modèle finalement très complet
de façon à offrir effectivement une
vraie souplesse en termes de contrats de
travail pour que le médecin puisse
consulter et pour le coup en
saône-et-loire lorsqu'il vient dans un
cabinet donc préparé par le département
il ne fait que ça puisque le département
prend en charge toutes les questions
administratives
gérard larcher c'est de votre point de
vue point de vue des usagers ça vous
semble une bonne solution
oui enfin a priori je trouve qu'il
répond très bien à la demande de son
département
la difficulté c'est que c'est tous les
départements font pareil il y aura pas
assez de médecins
donc moi j'ai un autre point de vue là
dessus c'est l'élévation du niveau de
compétences de tout le monde je
m'explique est ce qu'on appelle les
infirmières de pratiques avancées avec
l'infirmière qui peut prescrire certains
médicaments dans le cadre de soins de
suites etc
mais il ya aussi les sages femmes il ya
aussi les kinés il ya aussi et les
psychologues
on avait récemment laissé coi que les
médecins fassent un peu moins avec
d'autres gens grâce un peu plus à ce
qu'ils font mais qu'il soit aidé du fait
on est clair dans les dix ans qui
viennent on est en déficit de médecins
donc on peut les recruter plus un
endroit qui est un autre mais ça pose un
problème donc une des solutions c'est
d'élever le niveau de compétence des
gens qui entourent les médecins de
manière à soulager les médecins d'une
partie des activités
mais moi j'y crois beaucoup et je dis et
ce à quoi on avait récemment une
commission santé mentale en manque de
psychiatres mais dans son nombre de cas
quand quelqu'un a des difficultés
familiales avant de péter les plombs
il aurait peut-être pu discuter 10 20
heures avec un psychologue qu'il veut
rayer qui l'aurait aidé à remettre un
peu les choses en place en perspective
il aurait peut-être pas eu besoin de se
retrouver dans un hôpital psychiatrique
et ça c'est vraiment un truc fort il ya
2 il ya deux nouveaux métiers on va dire
qu'ils sont évoqués dans ce plan santé
c'est coordinateur de soins et c'est
assistant médical
fadila khattabi effectivement il est
prévu d'avoir créé des diplômes y avoir
créé des études c'est bien sûr c'est un
nouveau métier assistants médicaux ce
sont ces afin de libérer du temps
médical pour les médecins les décharger
de certaines tâches administratives
préparer la consultation ses assistants
médicaux pourront également par exemple
prendre le poids la tension etc et
dégager du temps et apparemment on
pourrait ainsi gagner 2000 postes
supplémentaires vous allez dire ça reste
quand même insuffisant mais c'est quand
même mieux que rien et donc c'est
vraiment il faut réorganiser et
améliorer les conditions de travail des
médecins est ce que c'est pas en même
temps moins de temps passé par le
médecin avec ses patients émerveillant
si c'est pas plus doivent pâtir du
médecin veulent effectivement travailler
en coordination
donc soit avec des paramédicaux
effectivement quand même besoin psycho
infirmières soient effectivement avec
d'autres types de professions soudain
médical ou cornet atroce en particulier
pour faire les ags de raconter la fin
des examens complémentaires qui vont
être soit télémédecine soit non
télémédecine qu'on fait de plus en plus
justement en ambulatoire pour éviter que
les gens se déplacent jusqu'à l'hôpital
et donc ça on a besoin de ce temps qu'un
peu administratif ou médico-social voilà
mais qui vraiment nous décharge pour ses
examens là tout temps nous gagnons du
temps consultation auprès des patients
ce qui a été montré dans normandie fait
en médicaux et assistants médicaux si
justement qu'on augmente est plutôt
notre temps avec les patients pour dix
minutes administratif on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya eu plein d'expériences menées
dans plein d'endroits en réalité jusqu'à
demain vous voulez réagir c'était sur
lewis était un peu vis à vis de mon
voisin évidemment que le modèle le
groupe uni les ornières vous piquez les
médecins à d'autres départements en fait
lors entièrement gelé un peu de sang des
médecins n'exerce pas c'est à dire il
faut le savoir en sortie d'université
après l'or leur cursus 20% ne pratique
pas de médecine ensuite déjà et donc du
coup moi j'en ai récupéré quelques uns
deuxièmement évidemment le modèle de
saône et loire ne s'applique pas à toute
la france
évidemment j'en ai bien conscience même
si j'ai pu être auditionné simplement
c'est en attendant je suis président da
département je suis là pour régler bien
sur cette problématique dans ce
département
et c'est en attendant l'efficacité
d'éventuelles mesures que j'ai voulu
prendre cette solution qui allait être
insupportable dans au niveau de la
population de
ce département et c'est pour ça que je
remet finalement des médecins est
vraiment dans tous les lieux de ce
département mais pas en concurrence par
rapport aux médecins généralistes qui
font un travail formidable qui sont
vraiment en souffrance d'ailleurs et met
vraiment en complément et je rôde
dispose donc je redistribue finalement
des médecins sur l'ensemble du
territoire que ce soit rural ou urbain
comme à chalon bientôt lieu vire au
niveau des départements se plaignent de
ne plus avoir d'argent vous faire un
héritage vous avez fait quoi pour
réussir à faire ça non pas du tout le
modèle économique s'équilibre à partir
de 30 médecins généralistes c'est à dire
puisque le département en caisson les
consultations il faut trente médecins
équivalents temps plein pour équilibrer
le modèle économique et donc il n'y aura
pas bien sûr on a mis au départ 2
millions d'euros d'argent sur la table
pour construire l'entreprise
mais au bout de trois ans normalement
les comptes seront équilibrés et
d'ailleurs j'ai pris le soin de mettre
un budget à part pour pouvoir le prouver
au niveau des citoyens que finalement
l'investissement aurait été équilibré
vous avez dit un mot tout à l'heure une
expression c'était plus de médecins vous
pouvez manquer de médecins prédit la
cata vie dans la réforme il ya la fin du
numerus clausus est ce qu'on doit
comprendre ça pour comme on veut plus de
médecins sur le marché ou est ce que
l'on veut améliorer les études de
médecine enlever cette difficulté
extrême de cette première année dont on
sait que c'est c'est quelque chose de
très particulier c'est quoi l'idée c'est
quand même que y est que grâce à ça il
ya plus de médecins dans les campagnes
plus de 26 en ligne non mais il faut
déjà répondre à la question suivante
pourquoi le numerus clausus a été mis en
place
c'était surtout pour contenir les
dépenses de santé en maîtrisant la
démographie médicale ont constamment les
annonces moins de médecins ça coûte
moins cher on constate après des années
c'est ce qui se dit mais on constate
après des années
du coup et du coup effectivement ben la
dépense elle est là elle est bien cette
année pour la première fois il ya elle
est bien réelle et puis en plus qu'il ce
week en plus il merci monsieur miled de
souligner mais c'est peut être ce que
les russes n'ont vu non mais mais est ce
que je veux dire par là aussi on note un
gâchis enfin on a à peu près des
étudiants qui sont brillants qui
réussissent le bac avec mention bien
mention très bien qui se destine à une
carrière en tout cas médical et une
fille née il y en a plus que treize
mille cinq cents à la fin de l'année qui
sont reçues qui ont réussi qui sont
retenus donc quel gâchis c'est aussi un
investissement finalement qui est qui
est terrible et il ya la souffrance de
ses étudiants donc je pense qu'il vaut
mieux effectivement mettre un terme à ce
numerus clausus et construire les
parcours de formation différemment c'est
à dire ça ne veut pas dire effectivement
qu'on va mettre à mal la qualité de la
formation loin de là mais on peut créer
des passerelles par exemple après la 3e
4e années de métier de médecine et bien
certains vont effectivement pouvoir se
destiner à une carrière de médecin
et puis d'autres via des passerelles
pourront se destiner à une carrière par
un médicale ou autre
donc il faut effectivement réformer y
compris au niveau d'ailleurs la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur travaille
avec mon collègue olivier ferrand pour
voir comment on peut construire ce plan
de formation il ya deux choses à faire
que ont sélectionné par le bachotage
c'est peut-être pas le mieux sur des
médecins qui vont et dans le relationnel
qui est patient mais ce que je veux dire
ça fera plus de médecins généralistes et
des médecins de campagne s'il ya moins
de bachotage on verra bien mais
peut-être conception à différemment ces
gens là et que la formation va en
découler vivante et ô peut-être
effectivement on sait qu'en sortie de
fait qu'un certain nombre de médecins
qui ne pratiquent pas finalement un
métier est vraiment importante et mais
peut-être qu'on en aura un peu moins de
ce côté là et l'autre chose c'est que
jusqu'à maintenant était basé sur un
système de soins avec tout hôpital en
disant il faut faire du curatif
peut-être qu'il faut vraiment plutôt
faire de la prévention pour éviter
qu'ils arrivent à l'hôpital et là ça
fait des années qu'on en parle en effet
enfin que ça va arriver
on voit les chevaux petite hattie changé
sur le terrain pour l'instant nous
laisse continuer à le faire j'en attends
de voir en pratique avec nos agences
régionales de santé qui nous ont
soutenus jusque là pour que ça continue
je vous en fait quelque part le
dispositif de la salle noire c'était
pour répondre à une attente immédiate
parce que les mesures qui seront prises
mais c'est pas un reproche simplement
neymar est un petit c'est dans dix ans
c'est dans dix ans et c'est pour ça que
je ne pouvais pas supporter d'attendre
encore plus longtemps puisque on allait
rentrer vraiment dans une situation
catastrophique et c'est pour ça qu'en
saône-et-loire
finalement on pourra attendre
tranquillement confortablement
ce que j'espère bien deux joueurs de
voir cette longue marche 6 à 7 cette
question-là sera réglé chez nous
l'élément central de ce plan et vous
l'avez évoqué en parlant de prévention
aussi c'est l'organisation qui prévoit
que tous les médecins devront
s'organiser en collectivité laisser pts
communauté professionnelle territorial
de santé
voilà aurélien rayant vous vous présidez
le groupement du pays beaunois on sait
que vous avez fait partie de ce qu'on
est des modèles comment ça marche assez
pts déjà rapidement sans acronyme dites
nous à quoi ça sert et puis on va voir
si ça peut être une solution pour tout
le monde
rapidement quand les gens arrivent à
domicile et qui voit qu'il ya un
problème de maintien à domicile pour
faire simple c'est ce qui posait plus
problème dans notre communauté
il a un temps passé à communiquer avec
les aidants avec le patient avec les
services sociaux les paramédicaux et
donc nous il ya une infirmière
coordinatrice qui vient au domicile qui
va faire ce lien entre tous ces
personnages entre médico social pour
améliorer les qualités soit au domicile
si besoin et voir s'ils n'ont favorisé
ce maintien d' homicide et faire le lien
ville hôpital et ça c'est une révolution
c'est du temps passé et il ya aussi tout
ce qui est les parcours de soins des
patients sur les maladies chroniques etc
on essaye de faire en sorte que les
patients et justement est ce un bon
suivi et évite de retourner à l'hôpital
donc s'associer à un autre problématique
est donc c'est là où rendent tout ce qui
est du cas sion thérapeutique à la
population aux actions de santé publique
soit peu plus la subvention et attirer
les jeunes vers leur montrer qu' il n'y
a pas que les cabines groupe où les
maisons de santé pour travailler en
coordination ce qui attire beaucoup la
nouvelle génération ce qu'on refusait de
parler de façon de travailler
on peut être installé seul mais
travaille en coordination avec des
soirées interne
fonctionnel ou de travailler avec tous
les paramédicaux médecins du territoire
ou spécialistes du territoire un premier
second recours ont dit voilà les
généralistes et les spécialistes et la
via ces communautés il va pouvoir mieux
communiquer avec eux et donc ne pas
sentir isolé ne pas travailler seul
finalement gérard marché ce qui ressort
beaucoup chez les usagers
c'est ce manque de coordination ces gens
sont seuls ils savent pas le lien le
lien médecine hospitalière méthyle de
ville il a aujourd'hui beaucoup de mal à
ce faire il est censé se faire mais les
gens se retrouvent chez eux un peu
abandonné autant il était bien suivi à
l'hôpital autant alors on veut
développer l'ambulatoire ce qui est très
bien mais a cependant évoqué un
accompagnement et moi j'ai des
expériences vécues ou les gens se
retrouvent et se veut et est rentré à
l'hôpital trois jours après parce que en
fait mal accompagné ça s'était pas bien
passé du tout quoi donc il faut qu'on
fasse très attention pour diminuer les
coûts de la santé ont dit il faut que
les gens rentrent chez eux le plus
rapidement possible après une opération
ce qui est sans doute très bien mais il
faut que ce soit accompagnée effectué il
faut qu'il y ait cette coordination ça
c'est important
ok c'est dans le prononcé dans le projet
c'est très simple vous semble être une
bonne solution oui c'est sûr par contre
si j'ai envie de le dire ce plan de 54
mesure il est très bien on est dans les
voeux pieux c'est agréable de lire tout
ça faisons le parce que les urgences
aujourd'hui il ya un problème les ai pas
il ya des problèmes le lien on va
signaler d'ailleurs il ya un mot d'ordre
halte à dijon chu de suite grève des
urgences qui répondent maintenant et
c'est de ça dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui les problèmes ils sont
maintenant avec par exemple je rebondis
fade avec avis vous nous dites vous
allez allez voir légende des urgences du
demain je vous rassure que dans dans
leur mot d'ordre nous signale qu'un
certain nombre de postes par exemple
qu'ils absorbent le quinze de nos verts
ne sont toujours pas pourvus
on a quand même l'impression qu' un
grand plan mais au quotidien dans le
fonctionnement on va ouvrir le dossier
parce qu'il est compliqué mais excès que
c'est que c'est difficile en lien avec
ces urgences
il ya quand même dans l'obligation
s'organiser l'obligation de répondre en
première ligne pour que les gens
n'aillent pas aux urgences
oui tout à fait il y aura aussi la
création de 400 postes de médecins qui
vont aussi être en lien avec les
hôpitaux danse
les zones les plus défavorisées en
densité médicale on va mais pour la
médecine de ville aujourd'hui on va
rappeler qu'il n'ya pas d'obligation
aujourd'hui dans la journée d'avoir un
interlocuteur
les urgences du jour les messins à mes
collègues generali se font tous les
jours on n'a pas attendu une loi pour le
sien on répond on ne demande donc ça va
pas les engorger les urgences parce
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple clairement si
les pompiers ramasse quelqu'un il
l'emmène aux urgences traditionnellement
on allait plutôt essayer de voir le
médecin avant d'aller aux urgences et
les patients ont peut-être un effet de
faire le 15 plutôt que d'appeler son
médecin généraliste ça c'est un problème
où le futur numéro qu'on va avoir le
sens ya 117 pour nous contacter pour
contacter une régulation libérale
alors pardon c'est quoi ça ça va être un
numéro qui va voir mais on aura déjà non
j'espère au niveau national ce que pour
l'instant il ya peu de côté donc il y à
une régulation qui pose problème c'est
que c'est la régulation quand elle se
fait par un spécialiste ou quelqu'un de
mon d'hôpital et qui connaît peut-être
pas le monde de minéral et donc d'avoir
une régulation par les généralistes
c'est déjà quelque chose qui va être un
avance et on verra après ça se fera en
dehors des heures de permanence des
soins
mais encore faut-il effectivement que
sur le terrain les généralistes puissent
répondre à ces soins non programmés
donc soit nous on arrive à peu près à le
faire pour nos patients canton à cabine
groupe on va pouvoir s'arranger entre
nous pour avoir des heures qui varient
entre chaque professionnel santé parce
que voilà tout le monde n'a pas envie
d'un ami à 20h voire 22h vous voulez
monsieur matheron le mail à foug pa rla
faut pas rêver l'autre chose c'est que
il ya des fois les gens qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant et c'est là où du coup
nous dans des maisons de santé oms va
effectivement on dit là bas on répond
aussi à ses patients compagnie cintrée
temps parce que sinon notre rôle de
faire cette réponse sur un territoire
c'est là on va essayer d'y travailler
mais encore faut-il bien d'avoir les
désaccords pardon sur un grand
territoire je vous écoute on est
d'accord que jusqu'à maintenant ça comme
une situation des médecins généralistes
ils font leurs journées ils ont leurs
patients mais ils n'ont pas d'obligation
de répondre à des urgences ou à des
choses comme ça on est d'accord noces et
morale a dit oui moral mais on sait on
sait ce que vaut la morale andré
académique
un peu ça d'abord le médecin généraliste
libéral installé dans la mesure du
possible il le fait répondre et dans le
dispositif que j'ai mis en place sur
l'ensemble de la zone euro c'est-à-dire
les quarante cinq antennes les quatre
pôles il ya évidemment une plage horaire
c'est à dire il l'est prévu d'accueillir
effectivement cette problématique là
c'est à dire des patients n'étaient pas
prévus sans situations d'urgence
on peut les accueillir d'ailleurs
j'organise avec l'ensemble des hôpitaux
de saône et loire un maillage justement
pour m lorsque j'en aurai assez des
médecins généralistes aussi à
disposition des hôpitaux pardonnez moi
mais ce que vous décrivez là c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de vous
substituer à la rs enfin aux gens dont
c'est le métier et est ce que ça alors
c'est pas une critique assure mais ce
n'est pas le constat que des choses ne
sont pas faites
mais bien sûr mais en tant qu'élu local
pendant des années j'ai assisté à des
bilans à des diagnostics de situation et
il n'y avait pas de réaction donc on ne
pouvait pas laisser parce que ça
s'appelle la non assistance en personne
en danger
quand vous ne réagissez pas quand vos
pompiers sont sans arrêt finalement
interpellé pour faire des missions que
normalement démission c'est à dire
d'aller dans des étapes parce qu'il n'y
a plus de médecins généralistes d'aller
sur des territoires parce qu'il n'y a
plus de médecin généraliste vous ne
pouvez pas laisser cette situation et je
reconnais volontiers finalement d'avoir
pris la place finale d'autres
organisations
mais on ne peut pas laisser une
situation ce perturbé comme ça puisque
pertur et parce que vous aviez sur un
territoire qui est quand même là ce noir
c'est le département qui a le plus
d'habitants dans la région bourgogne
franche comté mais avec la moyenne d'âge
la plus élevée
vous ne pouvez pas laisser la situation
ainsi et il fallait bien une réaction
forte et immédiate sujet de la prise en
charge de la dépendance je veux dire on
a aussi effectivement une population qui
est vieillissante et donc il ya d'autres
besoins de nouveaux besoins
et effectivement on n'a pas pris les
mesures nécessaires pour pouvoir pallier
le manque de professionnels c'est une
réalité parce qu'on n'a pas pris les
mesures en amont sur
la volonté du gouvernement de répondre à
cette solution
je rappelle quand même que 400 médecins
salariés à l'échelle de la france c'est
3,96 médecins par département donc là
aussi il faut ramener les choses et
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu mesurer
mois le dispositif par rapport aux
finalement à l'efficacité sur un
département comme le nôtre et je pense
qu'il faudra attendre de nombreuses
années avant d'en sentir les effets
c'est pour ça que on ne pouvait pas
attendre vous vous intégrez juste un mot
dans l'organisation qu'on évoquait ces à
vos médecins ils vont rentrer dans des
groupements aussi de la même manière
bien sûr on n'est pas dans un jeu voilà
non mais qu'on se comprenne bien juste
parce que l'on me suis rapproché je
rappelle que je rappelle juste quelque
chose mais mon premier pôle est ouvert
depuis janvier 2018 donc c'est assez
récent et je ne peux pas encore
finalement répondre à toutes les
organisations en tout cas il ya cette
volonté évidemment de d'aller partout et
travailler avec tout le monde attend
c'est que on pourra pas mettre des
maisons de santé car tous les
territoires
d'où l'intérêt de ces communautés sur le
territoire c'est qu'on va couvrir une
population est pas une patientèle et sur
la population c est beaucoup plus dure à
s'organiser mais on y travaille et la
laj su lagence rien de santé en
l'occurrence que vous voulez pas qu'on
signe d'acronymes donc c'est vrai vous
avez demandé de les limiter
nous aide beaucoup là dessus on est
quand même pilote au niveau national
justement pour s'organiser sur notre
territoire on y travaille beaucoup avec
eux on va pas tout résoudre voilà en
quelques quelques années xavier environ
on est bientôt on a bientôt fini
oui donc on est en train de mettre en
place la sécurité sociale et avec ge à
groupement d'intérêt économique le
dossier médical partagé
moi j'entends parler de ça depuis 30 ans
j'ai le mien depuis quelques jours enfin
ça y est ça se met en place et ça c'est
très bien et je crois qu'il va falloir a
cité alors j'avais une réunion la
semaine dernière à langon parler de ça
et les mots je les recyots lui directeur
de bio les médecins n'étaient pas très
chauds aux gens comment ça va se passer
et c'est moi j'invite tous les usagers
allez sur le site va y avoir une
campagne de communication dans les
semaines qui viennent
allez sur le site ouvrir leur dossier
médical partagé dans lequel il permettre
toutes les informations qu'ils veulent
ou s'ils ont enregistré leur historique
de santé ce qui fait que si demain après
un accident il arrive aux urgences non
en situation de me parler
on pourra si l'on donné leur accord
accéder à leur dossier et éviter des
erreurs éviter des interviews de cette
musique tu le veux elle me dit que c'est
terminé
merci merci de 4 mais vous me regardez
pas
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour ce sujet qui est touchée alors
qu'on avait déjà un peu restreint la
médecine de ville dimanche prend ça on
se retrouve pour un nouveau débat ne
sera pas loin de notre sujet du jour
parce qu'il sera question de la
lassitude et des difficultés des maires
des petites communes et on ira faire ça
sur le terrain rester avec nous pour la
partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit jean
luc mélenchon ce sera un autre sujet bon
dimanche au revoir et merci
[Musique]